[Música]
y
en el último día de la convención
republicana se espera el discurso del
presidente de donald trump de aceptación
oficial a esta nominación que hicieron
los delegados el primer día de la
convención de manera no tradicional
también se espera el discurso del
presidente con los pilares más
importantes de su campaña para el 2021
si llega a ser reelegido y vuelve a la
casablanca 1 generar más de un millón de
trabajos en los próximos 10 meses tan
pronto llegue a la casa blanca también
generar una vacuna para el coronavirus a
finales de 2020 volver a la normalidad
en 2021 y acabar con la inmigración
ilegal en la frontera sur de los eeuu
también se esperan incluso apariciones
sorpresa del mandatario durante el día
de hoy
[Música]
última jornada de esta convención
republicana que desde luego ha sido
mucho menos virtual de lo que vimos con
los demócratas aún así aquí en las
calles de nueva york se ha vivido
también de una manera un tanto
descafeinada por la situación pandémica
en la que nos encontramos se ha echado
de menos el merchandising publicitario
de la convención republicana o esos
grupos de ciudadanos discutiendo sobre
los discursos de la noche anterior
también es cierto que la participación
de los representantes newyorkinos en
esta convención republicana ha sido
menor estaba previsto que se desplazará
a charlotte una delegación de al menos
100 representantes desde aquí desde
nueva york al final ha quedado reducido
a tan sólo 6 por la situación por la
crisis de coronavirus en la que nos
encontramos entre esos representantes
destacar la presencia de ellis stefanic
una emergente representante republicana
que en un principio no apoyó
especialmente a donald trump en el 2016
pero a medida que se fue celebrando el
juicio político el pasado año acabó
convirtiéndose en una ferviente
defensora del presidente
[Música]
culmina la convención nacional
republicana aquí en eeuu donde se han
tratado diversos temas como la fe la
familia la seguridad en el país pero
también se ha apelado al voto de las
minorías especialmente de las mujeres y
los afros estadounidenses en cuanto a
las mujeres varios de los oradores
dijeron que el presidente de trump ha
puesto a algunas de ellas en puestos
decisivos de la administración por
ejemplo la directora de la agencia
central de inteligencia en la cia y
otros puestos en cuanto a los
afroestadounidenses aparecieron algunos
de los oradores diciendo que donald
trump y el gobierno de eeuu han hecho
mucho más en estos cuatro años que yo
baiden en los 50 que lleva en diferentes
administraciones con todo consideran que
es importante ir a votar más que nada
porque creen que joe biden representa la
izquierda radical respaldada por países
como cuba y venezuela
[Música]